bonjour je suis très heureux d'être des
cas parmi vous aujourd'hui et surtout
très heureux parce que comme j'en ai
dans une business school
après cette conférence dans plein de
sujets différents de pouvoir parler de
l'audace de l' aventure dans
l'entrepreneuriat dans l'entreprise je
me suis fait repérer par par les gens
qui organisent ici parce que que ce soit
sur mon profil linkedin que ce soit sur
mon blog je me définis comme un
entrepreneur avec la particularité que
je considère que l'entreprise est
probablement la dernière aventure
moderne largement un petit peu parce que
on a constaté aujourd'hui que vous vous
y avoir la science ou un certain nombre
de choses comme ça mais ça va d'ailleurs
assez bien ensemble la science
l'entrepreneuriat et on peut construire
de belles choses je remonte un petit peu
dans le temps et je me mets une date
c'était un lundi 11 mai 1981 la plupart
d'entre vous n'étaient pas nés et je
passais mon premier et mon premier
concours pour rentrer dans une école
d'ingénieurs ou j'avais pris mes pendant
trois ans là-dessus masques etc et la
veille le 10 mai 1981 françois
mitterrand avait été hué et dans son
programme il y avait suppression des
grandes écoles donc on allait bavé
pendant trois ans on passait notre
premier concours et on se demandait
comment il allait pouvoir supprimer les
grandes écoles y en avait donc tous une
dent quelles que soient nos opinions
politiques on avait quand même tous une
dent contre les socialistes et on avait
une vanne qui disait en gros ça savez
vous pourquoi christophe colomb était le
premier socialiste du monde personne
il était le premier social du mot parce
qu'il est parti savait pas où aller il
est arrivé savait pas où il était il a
fait tout ça avec l'argent des autres
est bien la bonne nouvelle c'est que
christophe colomb était un aventurier
audacieux entrepreneur et socialiste ce
qui veut déjà dire qu'entre prenez un
socialiste est pas un oxymore vous aurez
déjà appris ça aujourd'hui elles
reprenant chacun des trois phrases et
voyons comment elle s'applique à
l'entrepreneuriat vous allez partir vous
savez pas vous allez c'est la vérité
quand on fait un business plan du
business plan à trois ans un
vieillissement à cinq ans qu'il fasse
personne ne sait dire ce qui va se
passer dans deux ans trois ans et sera
dans l'entreprise que vous montez et
arrière on n'en a rien à faire il ya des
idées il ya des concepts puis on se
lance donc tous les ans preneur les
entrepreneurs pardon partent sans savoir
où ils vont
on l'aurait contacté quand vous arrivez
vous savez pas où vous êtes à nouveau
comparé à votre business plan qui
étaient quasiment inexistants
vous savez pas où vous êtes et c'est pas
très grave parce que ce qui compte
finalement c'est d'avoir entrepris c'est
d'avoir créer de la valeur pour vous
pour vos collaborateurs
ceux qui nous ont fait confiance pour
vos investisseurs donc vous êtes on s'en
moque et je rigole pas en disant ça
prenait un des plus gros succès de
l'internet français des plus grosses
valorisation des plus grosses création
de valeur c'est se loger se loger leurs
business plans idées géniales
nous allons supprimer les intermédiaires
dans les transactions immobilières
une farce 90 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires ils le font en vendant des
annonces à des agences immobilières
donc moi j'aimerais bien offert aussi
pire que et ça va pas non plus où
j'arrive
mais avoir été capable de créer autant
de valeur et troisième point vous faites
tous avec l'argent des autres
alors ça c'est extrêmement important
aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas avoir la
prétention d'être le premier à avoir une
idée on est dans un monde qui est
globale si elle nous ça c'est pas une
chance d'être le premier il n'y a aucune
chance aux premiers rôles
donc pour avancer dans ce monde global
il vous faut absolument dollar
absolument du financement parce que ce
qui compte c'est pas l'idée c'est
l'exécution de votre idée donc vous
allez aller chercher de l'argent pour
pouvoir exécuter vite et je l'espère
bien votre idée est là il fallait il va
falloir être très audacieux d'abord
parce que c'est pas du tout facile de
faire en sorte que des investisseurs
crois en votre histoire crois en votre
capacité à exécuter l'histoire et puis
la deuxième partie de l'audace qui est
très compliqué c'est qu'en fait il va
falloir apprendre le plus d'argent
possible et le moins d'argent possible
en même temps donc c'est un peu la
quadrature du cercle si vous prenez trop
d'argent trop tôt vous allez donner
prend une trop grande partie de votre
société à vos investisseurs vous allez
avoir trop de cash
vous allez voir le brûler n'importe
comment et si vous n'avez pas pris assez
vous êtes très fier de vous parce que
vous n'avez pas diluer votre entreprise
mais vous n'allez pas prendre de risques
vous allez aller doucement
et puis il y aura un peu plus grands
lacs ira plus vite et chivu dépassera
donc vous avez compris
christophe colomb les socialistes les
entrepreneurs l'audace et quand vous
avez invité je me suis dit on peut poser
le décor on peut dire que l'entreprise
il faut être audacieux l'entreprise
c'est une aventure mais qu'est ce qui va
leur rester demain si tout ce que je
fais sur cette scène si vous expliquer
pourquoi je suis audacieux donc je me
suis dit que s'il devait vous restez
quelque chose il faudrait que vous avez
quelques clés
la première clé je voudrais vous donner
c'est comment est-ce qu'on devient
audacieux la deuxième clé que je
voudrais vous donner c'est quel est le
bénéfice d'être audacieux parce que
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire
d'être audacieux si sa chair pas à grand
chose
et troisièmement une fois vous êtes
audacieux vous avez compris le bénéfice
d'être audacieux comment vous faites
pour faire 2
vous faites pour faire en sorte de
rester audacieux et éventuellement pour
que les gens qui sont autour de vous les
gens qui constituent votre entreprise et
votre entourage de bienne est audacieux
alors commençons par les bénéfices
d'abord calé bénéfice d'être audacieux
c'est ça la merveilleuse nouvelle pour
vous jeunes peut-être entrepreneurs
c'est d'ailleurs la seule bonne nouvelle
que vous avez parce que les grandes
entreprises elles seront jamais
audacieuse jamais elles auront plus
d'argent que vous plus de talent que
vous les meilleures équipes des
influenceurs tout ce que vous voulez
mais quand vous avez un bon poste et
vous êtes quelqu'un d'intelligent dans
une grande entreprise vous prenez jamais
de russie jack et c'est pour ça que les
grandes entreprises rachète est petit
si vous regardez ces cinquante dernières
années et on nous rabâche aujourd'hui
les oreilles en nous disant regardez
airbus regarder le tgv et regardez le
nucléaire français et j'en passe et des
meilleurs vous pouvez me citer le nom
d'un entrepreneur qui a décidé de faire
une de ses sociétés
aucun en l'occurrence wick jeannin
contre les socialistes
c'était de la planification économique
et c'était un président qui était
professeur de lettres agrégé pompidou
qui a décidé de faire des centrales
nucléaires des des affaires airbus etc
c'est tout ça pour dire que votre chance
c'est comme vous avez rien à perdre
vous avez un bénéfice très important à
être audacieux
c'est ça que les autres n'auront jamais
et c'est pour ça que les grands vous
achèterez la deuxième raison c'est
comment est-ce qu'on devient audacieux
et d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est
finalement l'audace l'audace et de
pouvoir faire en sorte de pouvoir
risquer quelque chose et de l'assumer
alors évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
facile et c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour vous c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'être audacieux à 20 ans cac 40
parce que c'est beaucoup plus facile de
manger des spaghettis tous les soirs à
20 ans que d'en faire plonger à sa
famille à 40 ans et je rigole pas quand
je suis revenu aux états unis et que
j'ai monté oxatis au bout d'un certain
nombre de mois nous avions 50 abonnés et
le moins suivantes sont pressés à 60
abonnés nous payer chacun 20 euros
faites le calcul
nous étions passés de 1000 euros le
chiffre d'affaires à 1200 euros
d'affaires en croissance de 20% manuelle
offre mensuelle ça impressionne mais un
jour ma femme m'a dit en rigolant
heureusement quand pape sur ça pour
manger et elle avait raison
elle m'a supporté elle m'a soutenu et
c'est ça qui est très important comment
vous allez avoir de la confiance c'est
parce que derrière vous allez avoir des
gens qui vous soutiennent qui vous
supportent et comment vous pouvez
acquérir de la confiance en vous qui
sous-tend l'audace parce que si vous
n'avez pas de confiance n'avait pas
d'audace et bien vous le voyez
probablement par tous les gens qui
passent sur cette scène si en ayant des
patients quand vous avez des patients
vous avez le temps vous trouvez ça
jamais difficile de travailler ou de
vous impliquer dans vos passions vous
regarder ce que font les meilleurs vous
comparer aux meilleurs vous n'avez pas
peur de l'échec parce que vous voulez y
arriver et c'est dire donc que votre
passion soient sportives parfois c'est
le sport qu'elle soit artistique que
vous aimiez le théâtre que vous aimiez
la musique que ce soit d'être un roi du
jeu vidéo que ce soit d'avoir un hobby
aucune importance ce qu'il faut c'est
avoir des patients les esprits mais au
maximum après ils viendront les passions
professionnel et si vous arrivez avant
des passions vous arriverez à prendre
confiance en vous moi j'étais pas un
gamin particulièrement sur deux mois
particulièrement confiant en moi et
j'avais deux passions une pour un sport
la voile où j'étais plutôt très bon et
ça m'a donné confiance en moi confiance
par rapport au fait que je pouvais
gagner les autres confiance par rapport
au fait que je pouvais maîtriser un
élément la mère qui était pas si évident
que ça et je pense que ça m'a beaucoup
développé beaucoup aidé de même passion
que j'avais une autre passion qui est
plutôt à auby j'étais un fou de modèles
réduits et ça va donner la confiance en
grenache été capable j'ai découvert que
je pouvais construire ce que je voulais
jouer cas c'est ce que je voulais je
pouvais inventé ce que jouer ça n'avait
pas une grande importance
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut que vous saisissiez nouveau
quelle que soit la passion vous avez
essayé d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette
passion et de prendre confiance
les gens qui vous entourent bien entendu
ils ont beaucoup d'importance dans le
fait de vous donner envie d'entreprendre
ou pas alors d'abord le premier conseil
c'est vous virer tous les cas sans tous
les mecs qui vous disent que vous allez
rater
c'est là que ça va être difficile et on
s'en fout ça va être difficile
oui on peut rater et c'est justement
pour ça qu'on entreprend je me souviens
j'avais probablement votre âge et je
voulais monter c'était probablement pas
ma première entreprise mais peut-être la
deuxième comme ça et je discutais avec
mon oncle et je lui dis est ce que tu
penses que mon père tout réinvestir dans
ma société et il m'a dit c'est une très
mauvaise idée
et il le fera pas parce que ton père il
est là pour t'aider
si t'arrives un problème pour donner
confiance en toi ton père sait-on
parapluie atomique et on commence par
une bataille en sortant là-bas tomic et
cette phrase je me rappelle quarante ans
après parce que finalement il y avait
trois clés au quartier là dedans il y
avait le fait qu'ils me disaient tu as
pas besoin de tes parents pour réussir
il y avait une deuxième chose qui me
disait si tu es dans l'ennui
tes parents seront là et il m'avait
donné aussi une priorité sur quelles
sont les choses importantes au début
voilà donc pour avoir d'audace ayez
confiance en le troisième point qui me
semble extrêmement important
c'est une fois que vous avez cette
audace une fois vous la voulez
développer
comment faire en sorte de la transférer
aux autres et bien une seule secret pour
la transmettre aux autres les américains
appellent ça c'est les mauls chaque fois
que dans une entreprise vous avez signé
un contrat que vous avez un
collaborateur qui a réussi quelque chose
et ce terrain il faut le célébrer il
faut le célébrer parce que c'est ça qui
donne un envie d'entreprendre une audace
à toute votre entreprise à toutes vos
équipes et si vous voyez toutes ces
start-up américaine où on pense que
c'est cool et c'est en fait les gens
travaillent beaucoup
on en retient qu'une chose qu'ils font
beaucoup la fête c'est parce que ça aide
énormément
notre secret aussi par rapport à ça si
vous voulez vraiment garder le
transmettre votre audace
c'est que chaque fois que vous
réussissiez dans l'entreprise c'est
toujours grâce à vos collaborateurs
s'est jamais grâce à vous et chaque fois
que vous ratez c'est à cause de vous
ceci vous fait ça tous vos
collaborateurs vont devenir audacieux
parce que vous venez de leur enlever la
peur de l'échec qui est vraiment la
condition
pour pouvoir réellement avoir de l'eau
tu as donc en conclusion entreprenez
ayez de l'audace week c'est pas
compliqué il ya des règles pour
l'acquérir pour s'en servir pour la
transmettre aux autres et une fois que
vous aurez acquis ces règles vous
pourrez rapidement développer des
entreprises
mon conseil ça sera aussi les membres
rapidement d'abord parce que vous
investisseurs seront contents et ils
vous reprend confiance
la prochaine fois vous êtes vous
deviendrez un serial entrepreneur
deuxième chose c'est que garder une
entreprise longtemps et j'en sais
quelque chose et qu'oxatis ça fait 14
ans que je les ces problèmes en
l'entreprise que j'ai depuis plus
longtemps si l'on sait difficile mais on
a eu raison beaucoup trop tôt donc on a
six ou sept années au début où on
agirait pas garder notre temps mort est
allé doucement et le fait de dapta doute
modifier le modèle économique d'une
entreprise qui est mature c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile donc créé
avant c'est allé vite
ayez de l'audace transférer votre audace
à vos collaborateurs vendez votre
entreprise et créer dans une autre est
bonne après midi